game of thrones season 8 is the best
season of the show and here is why
just freaking kidding you actually think
this pile of horse vomit is the best
season of the show oh my gosh no says
the same four lines danny destroys
king's landing after they surrendered
like a whining babied bran becomes a
comadost vegetable who just stares at
people
tyrion becomes a mentally handicapped
version of himself who thinks a crippled
pile of dirt should be king the white
walker story is just as relevant as the
meaningless golden army cersei becomes
obsessed with elephants captain jack
sparrow is the cringiest villain to ever
grace television
arya somehow forgets all of her faceless
assassin training and never uses it
harris becomes a gossiping tween who
tells everyone he's committing treason
jon gets a free pass for killing dany as
if he was playing monopoly
so sword who doesn't understand the
concept of borrowing money becomes
master of coin and the whole season
drops more plot lines than any other
show because dumb and dumber didn't want
to do more than eight seasons and wanted
to bail on the show for money to work
for netflix
but yeah this is why game of thrones
season 8 is the best season in the show
happy april fools you average game of
thrones enjoyer